he might be the head of one of the most
important luxury fashion houses in the
world but Kim Jones is from London is
only in his mid-30s he grew up the son
of the geologists traveling the world
and he does the same thing to get
inspiration for his collection the stuff
is luxurious
the stuff is covetable but at the same
time it's real and it's wearable legit
more when I look at the Louie Vuitton
spring collection I see two things first
I see all this world travel inspiration
but then I see street where what to you
was the key takeaway right off the bat
it was the satin jackets of all the
embroidery I knew had been to Southeast
Asia right I knew that like there was
some Vietnam influence there this was
just like right out of the gate it was
like I can't wait to see this thing and
actually went stunned I want to see it
again right first I want to see the
whole thing come out and then I want to
go behind the scenes and get in there
and see all those details that he does
became what should we what does it take
to get all of this here it's it takes an
airlift because it's all I got - coming
from Paris
maybe this silk shirt will only they'll
only get five of them in New York once
they're sold out they're right out so
maybe there's maybe there's 50 of them
for the entire world right this was like
a real standout piece and question
there's so many chest stripes out there
and there's so many black stripes out
there but the fact that he's combined it
almost in this like tee design and then
he got into this whole denim grouping
what we sometimes joke is the Canadian
tuxedo yeah my mind immediately went to
old like hip hop Street where like Karl
Kani Rocawear oh that reference and then
but then when you touch it this is
really something different yes this is
not 90s denim this is like paper thin
seems like everybody the season was
doing some form of camo
yeah the old urban camo is almost like a
water detail to it it's almost the other
ripples in the water maybe he was like
aunty's he did this taped raincoat which
I thought was a great it's almost like
an inside-out Ranko right that thing is
like three ounces yeah this is like the
weight of one sock I might add it's
leather what yes varsity jacket we
noticed today you pointed out that
there's a little bit of a monkey pattern
in there yeah bamboos on trees honkies
in the trees he grabbed from the
archives a very old 80 year old print
took the print exactly how it was done
with the logo on it and recolored and
did in this
super-sick amazing color combination so
unbelievable just kind of move and this
these flaming you know hot colors well
let's start over here at the table look
at how the logo is white on white it's
like subtle it's cool it's it it's got a
classic shell toe design but it and it's
got a little bit of a low profile but
it's unbelievable and it's like you know
the classic will be Vuitton print but
shadowed out get it I love that and
we're super into high tops this season
yeah when they're really refined like
this white ones wearing with a suit wear
with a suit I'm wearing these with a
suit
crazy about this knapsack that he did
and you know Louie Thanh is all about
accessories and leather goods they have
a history of it yep and what Kim has
brought to the brand is changing that
every season when you buy it you're
marking that time you are buying that
season's version of that bag and it's
not going to be available next season
exactly as this thing breaks in and it's
always gonna take you back Jim you've
done shoes you've done a bag which is
cool yeah when you only get five that
means you only got three left for
apparel so choose wisely my friend
of course this is that jacket that
really stood out yes to me to all of us
but you know if you look at the bones of
it it's an American baseball jacket he
doesn't want you to walk around and
treat this very preciously right like he
actually wears this jacket himself with
a t-shirt approaching how passively
takes it off in the studio or is it on a
chair it's not treated like a mine silk
that it is exactly I love this for so
many reasons especially because the
color yeah it's this heightened intense
blue that we've been talking about it's
not that navy blue suit that every guy
hopefully has and we love navy blue
suits
it's a mohair mix so it's got a little
bit of that you know Mad Men era you
know fabric but it's completely modern
with with the drop notch and it's going
to be nice and cool because it's
completely unlined
I'm going to go to these track pants
we're loving track jackets this season
and I think this is just a really clever
matchup of something lounging like a
pajama but also the fact that it's very
active inspired I mean you put those on
and you watch about 12 hours of Netflix
and just feel like a king Jim can I have
two picks this collection is too good I
got to have to pee to it you got to do
I'm going right here the Panther if I
bought this I don't know I might have to
hang it on my wall for like six months
and then try to put it on and get out of
the door but first I would just want to
look at it myself I like the idea of it
just over a black t-shirt black jeans
and like you I'm gonna pick an accessory
hey mind if I hide behind yet come on
over shadow monogram the man who climbed
fashion Mountain backpack and I'm just
gonna if I had this bag I would wear it
every day
treat it like a $60 backpack that I
bought from the Sports Authority and you
know what it's gonna last forever
because it's got that Louie Vuitton
quality right so guys Jim and I have
taken you through the Louie Vuitton 2016
men's collection come back for more
leave a comment and we'll see you very
soon thanks are you taking my jacket I'm
taking it for you thank you